do you ever worry that like it almost
happened to you too fast all this
recognition that maybe you should have
struggled even more you know what I feel
about that era but the age thing is like
because it happened when I was 13 it was
like there's a part of me that feels I
did miss being a teenage like I didn't
get to be a teenager like a normal one
like more and more I get more grateful
for it happening young because or that
young because I feel like if it had
happened later then people would be able
to dig up dirt from when I was that age
like if this hadn't happened at that age
I would have been doing some reckless
[ __ ] you know what I mean yeah you know
what I'm like you know what I'm saying
like I feel like I I mean I can't even
think of an artist that hasn't had
something happen where they found some
dirt they found something they said do
you worry about that that like now let's
say you date a dude right or phineus
you're dating a woman or and now all of
a sudden you haven't had that time to go
around and do weird [ __ ] even like to go
out and experiment with stuff yeah just
to find yourself to make mistakes yeah
that's a big part now you can't do it
first of all where are your parents
yeah in the room the whole brother and
sister thing first of all is a little
scary
because think about it Oasis Black
Crowes I've interviewed all these guys
they can't stand each other after a
while and they're so brilliant together
could you ever envision resentment
between the two of you and perhaps not
talking to one another and not being a
team fully No right I don't know why do
you love your brother yeah so much yeah
he's my brother but it's like we're
great friends like we just are things
you get resentful that Billy gets to be
the front person and you mean you write
you write the song well you write the
songs with her and all of that but is it
hard for you not to be as well-known as
your sister you know what honestly I
think she so deserves it like when I am
on stage with her cuz I play you know
sort of the setup I'm sitting here
playing behind her on stage I just watch
her like kill it every night you know
and it's very inspiring to me the thing
with
like I'm never gonna take credit for
something he does because I do so much
total right you don't you're not sitting
there jealous when you write so you both
can write songs he's way better at me so
yeah that he's so much better than you
say that in every interview your brother
is a better songwriter songwriter are
you better are you a better performer
than your brother in terms of performing
these songs is that the way I I don't
know I think I'm just better at Fame I
think I know what I'm doing a little bit
and I think Vinny's would hate this [ __ ]
out of my life